Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
I’ve always thought of myself as a hands
on kind of learner.
I learn better when I can DO things with what
I’ve learned.
That’s why experiments are one of my favorite
parts about science classes.
You get to test what you’ve learned by applying
it!
Meshing is the idea that a teacher should
match their teaching style for a kid’s individual
learning style.
Like using flash cards for those who are visual
learners!
Basically, treat kids like the special snowflakes
they are and poof!
All their school troubles will go away!
Buuuuuuuut not so fast.
The topic of learning styles is super complicated.
I mean there’s supposedly a lot of learning
styles out there.
One study from the Learning and Skills Research
Centre in London found over 70 different types.
Most of these are constructed as dichotomous
with opposing concepts, like visual learners
vs auditory.
That sort of thing.
So it’s hard to pinpoint what exactly what
we mean when we talk about learning styles.
That’s the first problem.
Another problem, There’s not a lot of empirical
evidence to support learning styles.
Sure it’s been studied, but most studies
weren’t well designed.
A 2009 study published in the journal Psychological
Science in the Public Interest found a “lack
of methodologically sound studies of learning
styles”.
The authors looked for a rigorous approach
to testing the validity of claims that learning
styles matter.
They laid down requirements for a thorough
investigation.
Divide people up based on their supposed learning
style, randomly assign them whatever method
of instruction, then test all the students.
Basically the authors were looking for an
experiment that “revealed a specific type
of interaction between learning style and
instructional method”.
The students who were assigned their preferred
method should perform better on the test.
They looked at lots of different studies and
found that lots of people will proclaim some
type of preferred educational experience.
But what they found was nilch.
Nada.
Basically of all the studies that are out
there, most rely on self-reporting for determining
someone’s learning style.
Self reporting… really isn’t the most
scientifically rigorous.
Those studies that were somewhat better had
contradicting results.
but that’s not so say it’s totally junk.The
researchers even caution that they aren’t
saying the same manner of instruction works
for all students in all situations.
People do differ in personality, temperament,
and ability, no one is doubting that.
Treating students as individuals probably
won’t hurt them.
So the best way to teach a subject?
Well depends on the subject.
The authors of the study use the example of
teaching writing.
Of course it’s going to be a heavily verbal
course.
And something like geometry is going to use
a lot of visuals to aid in learning.
As for the best way to teach a student?
Well one study published in the journal Educational
Psychologist found that people who are new
to a subject learn differently than those
who have more expertise.
In what’s called the “Expertise Reversal
Effect”, learning something new can overwhelming
someone’s working memory, they don’t have
any prior experience or knowledge to draw
upon, so they need more guidance.
On the other hand, those who are experts or
more knowledgeable about a subject might be
harmed by too much guidance.
People without a lot of experience learn better
by looking at examples and those with more
experience need to be more hands on, it’s
better for them if they solve problems by
themselves.
Other studies show that engaging students
is the best way to go.
One study published in the journal Science
found that a way to teach called “deliberate
practice” helped students do twice as well
on a test and increased attendance by 20%!
The trick?
This practice relies less on lectures and
focuses more on the students.
Students are first asked what they know about
a subject in a short multiple choice test
and they are encouraged to discuss what they
think they know with other students, then
once the teacher understands what the students
know or might actually be wrong about, they
are better able to deal with it and addresses
those problems directly.
I mean I’d much rather a teacher get right
to the stuff I have questions about than spend
whole boring class periods going over material
I understand.
And really, learning is so hard anyways, all
that over-thinking actually makes it more
difficult to learn, Crystal has the scoop
on that, in this episode right here.
So what do you think?
What’s your favorite way to learn?
Let us know down in the comments below